this is I think a point that the
university really hasn't understood in
my opinion and from my dealings with
them I think though on the surface they
say you know well this sure is just a
matter that should be reported to the
police and I don't think they understand
how difficult that is and how important
it is for somebody to feel like there's
some sort of procedural justice and that
people the university care what's
happening and the message that they're
sending is really we only care about the
perpetrator you know god forbid we
affect some young man's promising life
with no thought for how that affects the
victims who are by and large women and I
think it felt very unfair to me that you
know he finished his exams on time I
didn't i deferred my exams I started a
second degree program in the United
States late because of that my
performance in the beginning of my
second program really suffered and I
don't I never got the sense of the
university cared about any of that and I
don't think they really understood how
much of the emotional work that I've
done you know with with trained mental
health therapists and and other you know
support network how much of that work
has really been about what the
university did not just about the rape
itself